President Biden stripped to Maui getting
blasted as a lie filled debacle laced
with bizarre stories about himself and
of course nap time yet somehow Democrats
in the media think it was oozing with
empathy Joe and Jill interrupting their
ritzy vacation at a Democrat
billionaires Lake Tahoe Mansion to spend
about five hours to tour the destruction
Joe showing Hawaii he cares by appearing
to nod off during a ceremony honoring
the hundreds of Americans killed by the
fires and when he was awake Biden
connected to their anguish by talking
about a time when his cat almost died
I don't want to
compare difficulties but we have a
little sense Jill and I
what it's like to lose a home
enlightening struck at home
on a little Lake it's outside of our
home not a like a big pond I almost lost
my wife
my 67 Corvette
and my cat
put all kidding aside
I watched the firefighters
the way they responded
turns out that massive Blaze with a
small kitchen fire that got put out
within minutes the empathy tour didn't
stop there Biden had more bizarre
behavior referencing how hot the ground
was following the deadly fires
you guys catch the boots out here
residents of Maui not taking kindly to
Biden's visit hitting the streets
outside the airport to protest his
presidential motorcade with some holding
signs reading you're late and others
chanting go home Joe but the White House
and the Press saw the trip as the second
coming of Mother Teresa
he did serve as empathizer in chief
after five days of being mostly silent
on the issue publicly if you know this
President you know how much he cares
about people I think his empathy his
stories his way he connects with voters
he has empathy and a connection with
voters that press and DC pundits like me
don't fully give him enough credit for
it today Dana will be an opportunity for
the president to not only see the
disaster first hand but also to try and
provide that signature empathy that he
has been known for in his political uh
life all right I'm gonna throw up
through my eyeballs Jesse this this is
the scare I I I'm sorry but all the
gloves have to come off on this one
we've been hinting around the fact that
this guy is not President right he's
he's not there this is something that he
has been doing for supposedly decades
empathizing going to people in times of
suffering he can't even do that anymore
so if he can't do this that's to me the
big question if he can't do that can we
even begin to believe that he's running
the country no he's not running the
country he can't show basic human
emotion during a time when hundreds of
children are missing if George Bush
after Katrina came out at the ranch and
said no comment and then went back to
the ranch then on his second vacation of
August flew to Katrina and said you know
what my bathtub overflowed one day had
to just re-tile the whole floor you know
my dog almost drowned but you know I can
feel your pain and then fell asleep at a
solemn ceremony afterwards and then
notice someone's galoshes in knee-high
water and then flew back to Vacation
Greg this is so abysmal abhorrent and
the fact that people are still missing
and he has the nerve to say I can relate
he can't relate he cannot relate to
human beings at all he's done this his
entire career it's not empathy when you
make up a lie in order to feel like
you're a part of someone else's misery
he does this with his son he does this
at other hurricanes in floods and
wildfires he's a plagiarist and when you
do that what you're basically saying is
you are so insecure
that you don't feel like you're good
enough or able to connect with other
people on a deep human level that you
have to then make up something in order
to insert yourself into their suffering
and that is how you Bond you're bonding
through a lie and he did this when he
plagiarized he did this when he makes
stuff up out of thin air this is a
different moment
I feel like the rest of the country even
the media is starting to wake up a
little bit here and they're seeing how
crass and callous and cold and
calculating politically calculating this
man is to phone it in on a time like
this
something's changed and I don't think he
might be able to come back from this you
know uh Jessica I'm going to take your
side for once because I feel bad about
this I don't think this is his fault I
think he shouldn't be out there I think
that they you know obviously they can't
send combo out there because she's
embarrassing so they're stuck Wheeling
him out there and he doesn't know where
the hell he is this is really on the
administration I mean I can't you you
cannot defend that performance can you
Jessica tarloff
that's your real name I think it is who
would pick that name anyway
um
I don't think that he should have
obviously used that example and you
could have just easily said I've seen
the awesome work that firefighters do
all over the country this is a great
travesty Etc
um so I think that that was misguided
I can't buy into the idea that Joe Biden
has been conning the American public for
five decades in terms of media has the
qual no but people listen to him he's
been on debate stages he's gotten
elected and re-elected and re-elected
and re-elected and people really like
him that's why they supported him that's
why he won in 2020 because he was
someone who was connecting with people
he was the guy talking to the little kid
with a stutter right about how he grew
up and how he got past that and went on
to be running for president and then
eventually won
um so I'll give you
that that was a bad comparison but
there have been so many
Craven lies told about the timeline of
the response on this Jesse just said his
first comments were no comment which is
categorically untrue so that was on
August 13th the Wildfire started on
August 8th on August 10th that's when a
major disaster declaration occurred he
got the call the request from Hawaii to
do that it took him just 63 minutes to
sign that you send a piece of paper that
I'm talking about yeah and then public
comments just wait for it and then later
that day he was in Utah talking about
something else and he opened up by
commenting on what was going on in
Hawaii and how devastating it was listen
to what the governor of Hawaii Josh
Green said within six hours the
administration met our needs with
Federal movement I don't think that's
ever happened before the Maui County
mayor I wanted to say our response to
the president has been he called me I
asked for the help that we needed and
within two hours one of his cabinet
members called me to answer my question
we've been getting all the help that we
need that's the mountain there just just
pointing that in right and you don't
think at a time when there are hundreds
of people dead and there's another
thousand people that are missing that
the Maui mayor wouldn't have said Joe
Biden is lying to you when he says that
they oh you've got to be nice you've got
to be nice you have to be nice because
you're hoping for something you're
hoping for for all the things that he
got the FEMA Aid came in I saw
Republicans criticizing why do you only
give them 700 that's the FEMA limit this
thing about the ground the hawk ground
he was talking to a dog whose paws are
on the ground it's not like he's saying
what a guy talking about about talking
to someone are you kidding me this are
you the guy who goes to an inferno an
inferno where a thousand people and
children are missing because they cannot
get any idea they have been so destroyed
there's no odontology reports there's no
fingerprints there's no body frames
there's nothing that's why they can't
identify everyone and he talks to a dog
and he talks about the fact that he
almost lost a cat are you kidding me
that you almost lost the cat Jill and I
know what it's like to lose this guy has
been lying from the moment he came on
the political scene he has a lack of
empathy he is egocentric he's got a
condescending smirk whenever anybody
asks him a question from the Press he's
lying and he's narcissistic and you know
what it's not he's not trying to make
him feel like he's part of their misery
he's a narcissist and an ego Maniac
who's trying to make it about himself
and you know what I'll bet he got more
than seven hundred dollars when he had
that so-called fire in his house and on
the same day the fighting off for the
700 checks they he gave Ukraine 200
million dollars to kill you know what
I'm let me finish so what I want what
about the people in in uh who in Hawaii
who are saying we're Americans aren't we
why aren't we getting that kind of money
the people in Kiev have already gotten
in Ukraine 113 billion dollars seven
hundred dollars they don't have food
clothing shelter a home and they're
missing their family don't tell me 700
is enough and when he says no Kareem
Jean-Pierre doesn't know what the hell
she's talking about she says Joe Biden
cares about people Karine explained why
he said when they asked about the rising
death toll he said no comment the bottom
line is he systematically lies he says
he was Greek he was Jewish he was raised
in a Puerto Rican community and that uh
uh the Charlemagne the guy you ain't
black if you don't vote for me he's just
a narcissist who does not belong on the
world stage
person and you have empathy you normally
don't need your folks to sell it for you
sorry no no I was just going to say that
I mean I I I again I go back to the fact
that I I don't think this is his
responsibility anymore I don't think you
can have empathy when you're senile you
know I think he's really degraded into a
a different type of Joe Biden what do
you think you're tossing it back to me I
was going to defer my time to the
National Review on the Twisted idea of
empathy and I think this is a really
real important moment as Jesse was
pointing out earlier talking about his
responses to tragedies and these are key
moments for people who are really
grieving and going through a lot
something they could never imagine
having lived through on the ground there
these tragedies almost always involve
butchering the truth to make them about
him rather than the victims and Jesse
you'll appreciate the way they end this
piece he's Prince Philip without the
charm Kanye without the genius David
Brent without the script and hidden
camera come back no comment All Is
Forgiven and that's happening far too
many times and I think the American
people and to your point the Main Street
Media are seeing that happen all too
much can I just say two really quick
things okay one great I think they're
really good okay so the judge knows how
government budgets work the money for
Ukraine has nothing to do with the money
for Hawaii I also did not hear this kind
of criticism of Donald Trump's
characters when he threw paper towels at
people in Puerto Rico or comment about
the IG report from the housing
department that showed the 20 billion
dollars
and we're talking about Joe Biden and
the American people no one else no
you're talking about this person being
uniquely unempathetic incapable of
connecting with people and a liar no he
I mean look Jessica he is a liar we know
that it's been documented for decades he
has lied about everything I'm siding
with you I don't think he's evil I just
think he's lost his marbles well that's
obviously not the thing
I know Donald Trump went to every
National disaster that happened in
America and that's a fact all right we
got to move on coming up get your 50th
booster and wear 20 masks Liberals are
pushing covid craziness again hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else